a lot of people I speak to they're like
I'm gonna tattoo cuz I don't know what I
get that's a good thing I think you
should just take your time I think if
you can somehow display your story your
journey to where you are at that point
in your life my sister was engaged to or
ended up marrying a guy who was a tattoo
artist so I grew up from a really young
age I'm around 10 years old
viewing individuals getting tattooed
I've got a big cross on my back I mean
the idea originally came from tooth back
it was my favorite rapper and then the
ones putting angel wings around it and
then the toughest it still arise it took
like I think 10 hours or something like
that just in one go straightaway and
since then I've loved my back to the
point you know you check it out
once you kind of get your first one you
kind of move on to kind of wonder what
next can I get what what else kind of
connecting it with what else resonates
with me I've got a guardian angel here
for the Sacred Heart of Jesus here and
I've got an image of Michelangelo's
sculpture of Mary holding Jesus from
when she came up the cross so Mary's at
the front here and then you see Jesus
[Music]
I believe church on a Sunday thinking
wow I've really liked in my direction
where to go so church was really my
compass so I had that's why I got the
compass I've got family and faith on my
shoulders and very very close to my
family and we always get together almost
like a Thanksgiving kind of middle I
grew up for a period of time on an
American Air Base in England so I grew
up experiencing Thanksgiving so it's it
I've inherited that part Lions are just
the most incredible creatures I think
they're just ferocious aggressive as a
passion they're the leaders of their
herd they are the king of the jungle I
feel like I'm a lion at heart so I found
this really cool image of a lion and his
facing towards my heart I do have a
quote across my chest is from Marianne
Williamson it starts out our deepest
fear is we're not inadequate our deepest
fear is that we are powerful beyond
measure it's all about empowerment it's
all about strength it's all about family
and loyalty and just I guess your core
values I go out to China we have a race
in Shanghai and the fans there are
amazing I mean they're so passionate
about what we do they just follow you
around and they give you gifts they're
just so generous just beautiful people
and so when I was out there I was like I
wanted to get a Chinese symbol and so I
chose warrior because I feel that's what
I am and then love anything
I've always wanted to have something on
my hand and kind of just I put this scar
here it was a racing scar
when I was eight I got my hand stuck
under the go-kart while I was driving
and it went through my glove and right
down to my tendon that cut through pot
my tendon so I got a rose here I also
have a big rose on my on my right rib
which is from my auntie she passed away
five years ago from cancer it's not
finished yet still got to engrave it
with her name I've got the eagle on my
neck the reason I got the eagle is
because my best friend from from when I
was ten years old would call me eagle
eye because I'd see things really well I
mean see things from a distance now I've
got his love here God is just the most
important thing I guess in my life
there's been a couple that espera moment
blessed behind my ear I did that just I
was like I want to put them somewhere I
don't know where to put it I was like
how about back here in those moments
it's really kind of nerve-wracking
because you don't know how it's gonna
look my last one I just got my shoulder
and it said so really dedicated to my
dad so I wouldn't be doing what I'm
doing without my dad my dad was just a
great father and a great figure out for
me to look up to from the age of like
four I guess he would pick me up throw
me in the air as you do with kids and it
was the single most special moment that
I would really have in my dad because
he's a very very serious man he was very
very tough but in this particular moment
that's when he was the happiest there
was no business there was no discipline
needed it was just pure love so I got an
image of a clock there's a real special
moment in time and then him holding me
up in the sky we're on the stairs to the
pearly gates
in terms of what I'm gonna get next I
don't have anything from my mom who's my
favorite person in the world I've got my
dogs Roscoe and Coco which I gotta
somehow I'm in bed there for my skin
I've really just taking my time to try
to pick specific things that might
hopefully mean something to me
[Music]